U.S President Joe Biden from the air and
the ground seeing the toxic shell that
is left after wildfires swept through
the island of Maui Taking Lives in
thousands of structures more than 100
confirmed dead more than 800 people
still missing the four of the rapidly
spreading Flames still so very fresh it
was like if you pour gasoline in a line
and you just you know lit it on fire it
was so quick the pain of confirming the
dead this man's 16 year old brother's
body just found along with his beloved
dog they were found together hugging or
you know he
he'd probably try to save a man you know
he jumped on top of him and he hugged
him Biden taken out what many see as his
greatest political strength being able
to console those in need to understand
their suffering after all he has himself
lost his first wife and young daughter
and recently his adult son I know the
feeling that as many of the people in
this town this community
that Hollow feeling you have in your
chest like you're being sucked into a
black hole wondering will I ever will
ever get by this
you know it's one thing to know but it's
quite another thing to have to wait to
wonder whether your family member is
going to be okay
but there's also anger at the president
as the death toll Rose while he was on
vacation he was asked about it his
response no comment
he stayed on vacation only stopping to
celebrate the anniversary of a signature
bill in Wisconsin now in Maui and not
everyone is happy about it stay out of
our way
get rid of the red tape we don't need
you
don't come here White House officials
insist the president was working behind
the scenes residents have much to be
angry about at local officials even
warned of high winds the electricity
company didn't shut off the power lines
which may have sparked the fires the
fire hydrants ran dry leaving
firefighters no ability to fight back
the outside Sirens that could have worn
what was coming never sounded now the
president seen for himself what the
missteps meant the horrible cost and the
horror left behind
Patty culhane Al Jazeera
foreign